a senior Turkish delegation visits
Tripoli to discuss trade defense and
energy
and signs a deal with the
internationally recognized government to
cooperate in exploring and drilling for
oil and gas
it's vital to confirm the importance of
the agreement that was signed today the
memorandum of understanding concerning
oil energy and gas especially in the
shadow of the Ukrainian crisis and its
International economic repercussions on
the world
Libya has Africa's largest reserves of
crude oil but years of conflict and
political divisions have devastated
production an oil blockade by Eastern
forces launched in April led to
production slumping to 200 000 barrels a
day the country now produces 1.2 million
barrels daily but wants to do more the
Turks say they can help
the hydrocarbon agreement aims to reach
a win-win situation for both sides on
land and at sea for research drilling
for both Turkish and Libyan companies
with the memorandum signed on Monday has
angered some and reignited disputes over
a maritime agreement signed by turkey
and Libya in 2019.
that do created an exclusive economic
zone in contested Waters in the Eastern
Mediterranean both Greece and Egypt say
the internationally recognized
government in Tripoli does not have the
authority to conclude International
agreements but some political analysts
disagree
this is a matter between turkey and
Libya and Egypt has no right of
interfering or commenting on that I
think it's proper for Egypt to stop
interfering in Libyan Affairs and keep
to its own business
details of the deal between Libya and
turkey have not been published the EU
has called for further clarification
saying such actions could undermine
Regional stability and with tensions
already Rising many in the Eastern
Mediterranean are feeling concerned Mal
Trina Al Jazeera Tripoli